keeping with the couple's theme you will
definitely recognize this couple to
Jersey Shore's Mike the situation
Sorrentino his beautiful wife Lauren
thank you guys for joining us
how is freedom how does freedom feel oh
we have a lot to be grateful for I know
you just went through a tough situation
with the miscarriage how are you doing
with that we're doing okay you know we
he leads our family by example with
going through our past tragedies and
trains pick ourselves up and dust
ourselves off and he I looked at him
lost when I snap and I'm like I know
what to do I don't know how to recover
from this yeah and he you just kept
doing like the next right thing you got
ready for the day you know you just one
day at a time
and we're almost a month later and I'm
doing a lot better yeah yeah it's like
we had no experience in dealing with
this particular situation no pun
intended and you know we kind of relied
on our faith and we looked at each other
for support and I said honey you know
we've been through some rough situations
in life Prison addiction what did we do
and pretty much what we did was we
picked ourselves up we dusted ourselves
off and went right back to the basics
the basics don't very well equate to
success and that's what we did yeah and
by the way you're still trying you're
gonna try keep trying
yeah I also want to talk about your
sobriety yes and what you are doing it
because you've also taken this prison
stint and kind of turned it around and
you are really working with folks
including the banyan tree under center
right yeah tell me about that yes I
pretty much turned a negative situation
into a positive situation we are turning
four years clean and sober right now
okay and in doing that we are
celebrating and we partner with Banyan
treatment centers okay to spread
awareness about the disease of addiction
and substance abuse more often than not
you hear the negative stories in active
addiction okay I'm here to shed light on
the positive ones
okay the comeback is greater than the
setback and in fact we do recover you're
looking at it right now
yeah yeah how I want to ask you how hard
was it for you though how hard was that
recovery oh how bad did it get cuz you
were addicted to prescription meds it
was one of the hardest things I've ever
done in my life
you looked at your wife would what did
that because she could be secret so
speak on it because trenches with she
believed in me when I didn't believe in
myself what do you remember of him the
Attic it was challenging any was it was
fighting him against himself you know
what I mean it was his own behaviors and
and it was just really challenging and I
just relied on my faith to help show him
the light within himself because he's
the only one that could do it I couldn't
do it for him you look at this man now
and now what do you think of this man
he's the man I always knew he was inside
of him it's just he finally believed in
himself enough to be that person 100% of
the time what was about a moment when
you do uh I had ended up in treatment
for a third time and I thought to myself
like how did I get here
you know I never want to end up here
again and I made a promise with myself
right then and there that I would do
whatever it takes
put all hands on deck no excuses take
the suggestions of the professionals
okay and really really fight this thing
and that's when I got the results
obviously faith in God faith in myself
and faith in my future you know and
that's you know why I'm here I have the
blueprint for recovery and now you go
back and you speak to addicts and what
are they what's the reaction when you
walk in the room um you know what all
eyes on me and and I like that that type
of situation I'm trying to explain to
them that you know why I give up one
thing for everything you can give up
that one thing and have everything yeah
and that's what I'm trying to get across
the room because you know I have I'm
still an addict and there's a stigma
about addicts but I'm changing the game
okay I'm addicted to being my best self
now I'm addicted to living my best life
my beautiful wife work being grateful
you know so that's what it is I'm trying
to teach others to do the same the way
you're talking is like you're gonna do
something big in the recovery space yes
yes it's happening yeah yes hopefully
very soon we can make a good
announcement but we're working on
something in TV what
so recovery and hopefully in 2020 we're
gonna have a have a good situation all
right you know the other thing I look at
you and I see how healthy you are how do
you go to prison and get in shape it was
very hard it was it was it was very hard
only because it's hard to get fresh
vegetables in salad in prison okay you
got to know somebody so you got to get a
hookup yes to get good food yes if they
didn't like you you was not getting good
food if you couldn't watch I tried to
watch Jersey Shore a number of times if
they didn't like me they wouldn't put it
on
luckily they like me he's watching
Jersey Shore in prison but when it came
to the the salads and stuff like that I
was getting salads every day the guys
liked me so they hooked me up I didn't
ask you about watching Jersey Shore in
the prison in prison what was it like
seeing yourself on TV and seeing
yourself the way you were I'll be honest
I was very proud because I was under so
much stress while filming that show and
a lot of times I didn't even want to
show up to work because I was so sort of
not depressed but there was a lot going
on but I kept the positive attitude I
kept an attitude that you know if I
continue to put one foot in front of the
other you know what I mean the storm
will end you know and sure enough that's
what would led to success you know just
putting one foot in front of the other
we lost 40 pounds we got the situation
back my beautiful wife living my best
life and now I'm giving back with bang
and treatment centers yeah learn how
hard is it or do you worry when he goes
back into the Jersey Shore situation
that there could be an issue because
people are drinking people are having
their party how tough is that how hard
do you watch it where we are today I
don't worry about it at all I know that
he has a really rock-solid foundation
didn't step foot into that Jersey Shore
house until he already had two years
clean and sober so he had put some time
under his belt
then when the reboot happens last
January you know we were a little
hesitant about how it was gonna be it
was also his first time filming Jersey
Shore fully sober and and how he was
gonna fit in yeah and he he just you
know showed his authentic self who he
was today really into food really into
fitness and you know it bred through to
the to the viewers and it worked out for
him and now he's coming up on four years
clean and silver so it's we're doing
well yeah every day you work every day
yes it's a one-day-at-a-time thing
that's how we've gotten through any
struggle in life you're gonna face
struggles in life life is gonna happen
on life's terms how you walk through
that fire is what really matters I also
feel like your attitude will make you a
different kind of father that you would
be a recant weight so that happens and
yeah we're very excited to start that
chapter and we're moving forward like
you know I mean we're supposed to later
on try right I want to ask you you're
Joe I'm your Jersey Shore co-star
Angelina got married yes and um the
ladies roasted her a little bit
apparently it didn't go over well with
Angelina what happened explained
everybody no where is it now you know
what we can't really comment too much
about it cuz it's gonna unfold on Jersey
Shore family vacation if you don't know
when it airs it's on Thursday z87
seneschal were you surprised that it
turned into a situation um I was a
little surprised but at the end of the
day you're gonna see how it unfolds on
the show it's probably gonna end up to
be master ratings to be honest with you
and we're gonna see how would happen how
it all unfolds but that's really all I
could say about it but also
congratulations Angelina I know it was a
beautiful wedding
it was a beautiful wedding yeah just
some people left angry yeah no I don't
think so I thought we added listen I
can't tell you how how we ended the
night put it it ended up working out I
think all right
congratulations on all you do yes thank
you so much for all where we end yeah I
want to tell anybody that is struggling
from substance abuse or the disease of
addiction if you know someone or
yourself that suffering from the disease
of addiction we have a hotline with
people standing by okay to give you the
resources hit you're situated it is one
eight eight eight two seven zero five
seven one two that is good stuff I can't
wait for the show I know a show it's
coming someone's mom you couldn't tell
us right now but I know something's
coming
[Music]